I was gonna say Judi Dench tried to tell
a story about you and her
Buckingham Palace mm-hmm do you remember
this story in the throne room yes yeah
it was a very posh occasion every
occasion of Buckingham Palace is posh as
well I was sitting next to the Queen's
late sister Vanessa Kirby air of a
Princess Margaret so the banquet was
over and you were free to go around and
there was a sound of music playing you
know perhaps there's a dance going along
so Judi and I went along the corridor
and into what we both felt was a vaguely
familiar room there's a little band
playing and we had a little twirl around
the room and nobody else there I said I
think this is the throne room you know
where you got made a dame and I got made
a knight and you know the two Thrones
that for the Queen and her concert I
said but where are they she said I don't
know let's have a look so we we went on
dancing behind the band and they're
behind this sort of partition but the
Thrones oh so we sat on them
it brings out the worst in your
buckingham palace I was doing an event
there a sort of part of a concert and I
was given a dressing room which was it
was a guest room at the front of
Buckingham Palace and you looked out of
the window
you were right next to the year that the
bulk the balcony and I thought well I
could just go out there and have a [ __ ]
looking down the mouth certainly there's
a - searchlight on me and below the
policeman say sorry and don't forget
you're in Buckingham Palace
well about six months later I'm going
along to get some metal on this occasion
and as we came through the gates there
was the same policeman he said oh not
you two again
[Music]
you